et
on a perçu d'étape au point que l'étape
ont tous les organes auriculaire avec je
voulais pas le faire avec un résident
français parce que les réalisateurs
français on trouve des gens qui ont
envie de faire un lange et qui sont pas
forcément comme il faut où ils sont
inhibés et granger où ils sont
traumatisés on a identifié
sylvain comme quelqu'un de possibles moi
je suis quelqu'un qui travaille qui
traite façon très proche de la caméra et
en même temps c'était un style de film
complètement différent de ce que j'avais
fait dans le passé donc je voulais
vraiment découvrir un nouveau style une
nouvelle esthétique pour moi et c'est
vrai que sylvain vraiment deux grandes
qualités c'est que c'est un fou de
technique lycée montée il sait faire de
la musique qui sait tout faire sur un
film il cadre il a cadré beaucoup puis
moi j'avais vu surtout j'avais vu ce
topic toi parce que s'il avait trouvé le
truc sur la danse c'est bien possible
que tu vois ça me fait peur j'étais
danseur opus borsus est ici faire
marcher une histoire enfin il sait
transcrire sur le papier la manière dont
il voit le fils donc on a fait
énormément de repérage 60% à paris 30%
belgique et allemagne est à peu près de
10% au maroc donc ça a été un énorme
challenge on a filmé rien sur plateau
quasiment rien donc tout tout était
vraiment d
véritable c'est moins une collaboration
moi j'ai fait beaucoup de choses dans ma
vie
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de faire des
trucs où je m'éclate et avec sylvain je
crois qu'on s'est bien éclatés